right welcome back Scania sunrise on a
Tuesday Team GB they're going to attend
a reception at this morning at Downing
Street and but before they do that
they're here in the studio with one
group of them anyway who contributed to
all the success that went on there at
the Winter Olympics it's the women's
curling team so they won bronze guys
again it was that against the odds or
how you know how much were you favorite
for a medal and I guess I would like to
think we were we were one of the
favorites you know we've had a great
last couple of seasons we've had we've
had several major championships titles
under our belt and and we were winning
as reigning world champions so it was
tough it was a bit of a roller coaster
weeks but you know what to come away
with with a medal and to finish in a
high do nicely speaking there beside Eve
we've got Anna and then beside her we've
got Lauren yeah and then at the back
there we've got Vicky and Claire so
congratulations to you all Sean yeah I
mean I just thinking about that bronze
medal match I mean they're dramatic
matches because you lose and you don't
get a medal
you've got your medals which we can see
there that massive aren't they they look
bigger than they look heavy the way
you're picking them up I mean that was
really dramatic wasn't it yeah you
wouldn't hold that up to camera would
you just so we can yeah lovely excellent
there we go Hey a dramatic match I mean
if you come down from that they did and
it's been tough he's been tough to come
back down but I think and we had three
days after we won our match and before
we actually got medals so it was it was
a lot of adrenaline but I guess it's
moment you don't want to forget and I
know the girls are cherishing them as
well I mean you guys did you have any
idea that things were stopping in the
country people were stopping what they
were doing to watch what you were doing
I was in the gym and we I think we were
all relieved to stop what we were doing
just to watch here because we were all
exhausted but it was one of those you
know stopping moments in the country did
you have any idea where you're out there
video so we didn't actually know until
we stop playing and but once we got back
on we can I realized that Carolyn had
kind of taken off which is really good
to see
curling has kind of got this whole
newfound following that does that did
that last time round everybody thought
all curling's the sport coat is a sport
you never see it again for another four
years
so that that must be very annoying for
you guys we're thinking and hopefully
this year there's there's they've been
worn the ball and they've put things in
place so that they're there's a lot of
come and try curling events and that
will carry on to hopefully the start
with the season next time so that people
maybe don't give it just one going and
that's that they'll have to go back and
try it again
so whether you don't disappear now you
go often more competitions it's not that
you disappear for four years or anything
when is your next competition where you
off to
and we're we in a couple of weeks to
Canada and we've got our event there and
then world would come back home and then
go out again to Canada for a last Grand
Slam of the season so what is the pool
size of countries who actually play
curling how many countries play curling
I'd like to think it's expanding and
there's a lot of countries now involved
in the sport that years ago weren't
involved in the sport and Olympic Games
so it was a round-robin of ten teams so
they're there there is a lot of
countries out there but there's a few
countries likes of Australia and Spain
and these kind of countries do expect of
a curling team and we're now starting to
take it up you have to be Scottish to
play we're all Scottish and but
hopefully to try to expand the sport
what we need to do is teams is win
medals and that's exactly what we've
done so hopefully we can get a few more
facilities down down here in England and
really kinda expand it in Britain the
simple fact is there just aren't enough
curling rinks in England in Wales I mean
there are quite a few in Scotland but
just to spread it across the United
Kingdom there's one one curling rink in
England which which unfortunately is
it's not enough but as you said
hopefully within the success of this
team GB and not not just curling for all
the sports it did well hopefully okay
let me ask you when you were growing up
as a youngster were you very good at
mopping the kitchen floor this give you
a skill is this the sort of preparation
or did you know you must be very good at
polishing floors
you could say that but no I think I
think in is just a lot a lot of training
and hardware it gets us to work where we
are so no if then we've done great but
here's more unusual isn't it because I
think that's what people were fascinated
by because those people who make maybe
hadn't watched it in detail before then
looked at it and thought wow you know
how it works and everything how did you
first get into it well like a lot of
people don't know how much hard work and
training we actually do put into it it's
a very physical sport and I guess for
myself as well it's a very it's mentally
draining as well because I've got to
kind of be thinking for those of you two
and a half three hours and one wrong
decision I guess could cause you the
game so in for these girls they could be
sweeping for up to two and a half three
hours as well so a lot goes into it and
maybe not practice on the kitchen floor
but but we do a lot of practice in the
ranks yeah and what is it you burn about
1,800 calories each time the you player
game which is a huge amount and when
you're sleeping it's your heart rate can
go up to about a hundred eighty beats
per minute which is huge as well so you
know this sort of image that it's it's
like bowls and ice which is very calm
it's actually quite strenuous and a lot
of training goes into it I think I think
people quite a lot of people their
fleets that came to watch us and
actually realize and it's good that
Colin's getting the respect and
recognition that but actually because
they have said well lovely lovely thank
you I know a lot of people really
enjoyed watching it as a spectator sport
guys thank you very much dude and once
again congratulations thanks for coming
enjoy your dad dining street looking
forward to that